un nuevo naufragio de haitianos en su
camino a estados unidos este sábado un
bote que transportaba a 141 personas en
cayo cerca de la costa cubana los
médicos de la cruz roja los atendieron
tras ser rescatados en el grupo había 22
menores y varias mujeres embarazadas
llega nuestro días de travesía algunos
han manifestado que no han comido en
esos o ir entonces por eso estamos
tratando de priorizar terminar esta
parte de control sanitario para entonces
poder llevar la alimentación que hay hoy
día el jueves cinco haitianos murieron
frente a las costas de puerto rico
después de que los contrabandistas
ordenarán saltar al agua a los pasajeros
la semana anterior hubo otro naufragio
cerca de las costas de bahamas 18
personas perdieron la vida cuando iban
destino a miami accidentes por viajes
irregulares con contrabandistas sin
licencia que conducen de forma temeraria
las autoridades bahameñas acusaron a
cuatro hombres por homicidio
involuntario
están los grupos localizados involucra a
personas en eeuu involucra a personas en
haití es una pandilla transnacional
nuestros funcionarios encargados de
hacer y la ley lo harán tan pronto como
sea posible
los haitianos huyen desesperadamente de
la última disputa entre pandillas por el
control del territorio entre el 8 y el
17 de julio la onu denunció más de 471
personas muertas heridas o desaparecidas
una crisis de seguridad que se acrecentó
en 2021 tras el magnicidio del
presidente joven el mois un vacío que
los grupos criminales tratan de
aprovechar